[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الحلقه الجديده
من مستقبل الطاقه هذه ملفاتنا
مشاريع طاقه متجدده بقدره 28 جيجا وات
وقعتها مصر في كاب 20 ما مصيرها في الظروف
الماليه الراهنه
والمدير العام لايرينا يؤكد لمستقبل
الطاقه ان العالم بحاجه لمضاعفه مشاريع
الطاقه المتجدده ثلاث مرات
[موسيقى]
سجلت مصر في السنوات الاخيره طفره في
انتاج الطاقه من المصادر المتجدده لتتجاوز
سته الاف ميغاوات او جيجا وات من اجمالي
طاقه الشبكه الوطنيه للكهرباء المصريه
وسجلت نسبه مساهمه الطاقه المتجدده من
اجمال الطاقه الكهربائيه في مصر 20% تقسم
على الشكل التالي الطاقه الشمسيه اثنان في
المئه
والطاقه المائيه سته في المئه وطاقه
الرياح اثنا عشر في المئه
وتسعى مصر للتوسع في مشاريع الطاقه
المتجدده وخصصت لها اراضي تصل مساحتها الى
خمسه الاف200 كيلو متر مربع اي ما يعادل
ضعف مساحه لوكسمبورغ او نصف مساحه لبنان
استراتيجيه مصر تهدف لزياده مساهمه نسبه
الطاقه المتجدده في مزيج الطاقه
الكهربائيه والاستفاده من ثروات مصر
الطبيعيه والوصول بنسبه مساهمه الطاقه
المتجدده في هذا المزيج الى 42% بحلول عام
20 35 وفي ضوء هذه الاستراتيجيه تنمو
استثمارات قطاع الطاقه المتجدده في مصر
بشكل متسارع حيث شهدت قدرات المشروعات قيد
التطوير ارتفاعا ملحوظا لتصل الى
3570 ميجاوات استثمارات اجنبيه مباشره
تقارب ثلاثه مليارات ونصف المليار دولار
منها 78% لمشروعات طاقه الرياح في منطقه
خليج السويس على ساحل البحر الاحمر ذات
سرعات الرياح العاليه
و22% للطاقه الشمسيه
اهتمام مصر بالطاقه المتجدده له اهداف عده
فمن جهه تسعى القاهره لخفض فاتوره الوقود
وتحرير كميات اكبر من الغاز للتصدير ومن
جهه اخرى هناك مشاريع للربط الكهربائي مع
اليونان ومن ورائها الاتحاد الاوروبي ما
سيمكنها من دخول سوق الكهرباء النظيفه في
اوروبا
وستكون مصر مصدرا رئيسيا لانتاج
الهيدروجين الاخضر وتصديره للخارج خلال
السنوات القادمه فقد تم توقيع 23 مذكره
تفاهم لانتاج الهيدروجين الاخضر والامونيا
الخضراء مع اكبر التحالفات العالميه
والاقليميه بالاضافه الى مذكرات تفاهم
وخطابات ابداء الاهتمام من مؤسسات استثمار
عالميه اخرى على ان يتم تنفيذ تلك
المشروعات على عده مراحل
[موسيقى]
حول مشاريع الطاقه المتجدده في مصر كانت
لنا هذه المقابله مع الرئيس التنفيذي
لهيئه الطاقه الجديده والمتجدده في مصر
السيد محمد الخياط والذي اشار الى ان مصر
ستبدا العمل على مشاريع طاقه متجدده بقدره
28 جيجا وات تم توقيعها في كابتونت سيفن
مؤكده ان عدم الغاء اي من هذه المشاريع
لنتابع هذه المقابله التي اجرتها الزميله
فهم زايد
هدف مصر الوصول بانتاجيه الطاقه المتجدده
بحلول عام 35 الى 42% ومع المراجعه
الدوريه للاستراتيجيه المصريه للطاقه بيتم
اعاده النظر في هذه النسبه من عام الى عام
وايضا بما يتواكب مع التطور التكنولوجي
بالنسبه لي مؤتمر الكوب 27 في شرم الشيخ
في نوفمبر الماضي شهد في الحقيقه زخم كبير
في الطلب على الطاقه المتجدده وايضا
المشروعات المرتبطه بانتاجيه الطاقه
المتجدده يمكن تقسيمها الى ثلاث مراحل
المرحله الاولى وهو الهيدروجين الاخضر
ودخوله على الساحه العالميه للطاقه كاحد
المكونات
المستهدف مشاركتها في المستقبل في مزيج
الطاقه
وشاهد توقيع تسع اتفاقيات مع مؤسسات دوليه
وعالميه للاستثمار في مصر من ضمن 23 مذكره
تفاهم تم توقي على مدار الشهور الماضيه
ومن المنتظر انه خلال هذه الفتره القادمه
تشهد هذه المشروعات المزيد من الاعمال
الخاصه باجراء الدراسات وحصر المصادر
واعداد دراسات الجدوى وايضا ما يتعلق بها
من اجراءات المحور الثاني هو خاص بي انشاء
مشروعات الطاقه المتجدده وتحديدا مشروعات
طاقه الرياح لما تتمتع به مصر في العديد
من المناطق من ارتفاع متوسطات سرعه الرياح
وشاهد ايضا توقيع مذكرات تفاهم باجمالي 28
الف ميجا من المنتظر العمل على انشائها
لانها من ناحيه بتزيد من مساهمه الطاقات
المتجدده في مصر وايضا تقلل من الاعتماد
على الغاز الطبيعي والوقود الاحفوري
المحور الثالث والاخير وهو ايجاد اليه
لبيع الطاقه المتجدده للمؤسسات المحليه
المهتمه بان تكون امدادتها من الطاقات
المتجدده
مرفق الكهرباء اصدر التشريع المناسب لهذا
الامر ويجري العمل على اعداد الاتفاقيات
والعقود ذات السلام هل التوجه المستقبلي
لمشاريع الطاقات المتجدده في مصر ستركز
حصرا على انتاج الهيدروجين الاخضر بهدف
التصدير في ضوء قدرات انتاج الكهرباء
حاليا من الطاقات المتجدده وكميات الغاز
المتاحه الهيدروجين الاخضر ويكون في
متغيرات كثيره على الساحه العالميه للطاقه
سواء بالنسبه للحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
سلاسل الامداد وايضا
حدوث هذه الاضطرابات بعد عامين من كوفيد
2019 وضعت الهيدروجين الاخضر كاحد البدائل
المستقبليه لمزيج الطاقه العالمي من
المنتظر ان يسهم في
تقليل الاعتماد على الوقود الاحفوري
وتحديدا الغاز الطبيعي ولكن الهيدروجين
الاخضر احد المكونات الرئيسيه في المستقبل
التي يمكن ان تعت على الطاقه المتجدده
ياتي ذلك بالتواكب مع استخدام الطاقه
المتجدده في العديد من التطبيقات الاخرى
سواء في تحليه المياه باستخدام الطاقه
المتجدده في هذا الصدى طرحت وزاره الاسكان
في مصر والجهه المعنيه بمحطات تحليه
المياه اكثر من عشرين مناقصه لتوريد
وتركيب محطات لتحليه المياه على ساحل
البحر الابيض المتوسط وايضا البحر الاحمر
تعتمد فيه تغذيتها على الطاقه المتجدده
وايضا هناك السيارات الكهربائيه والتي
بدات تاخذ ايضا نصيب في السوق العالمي
ومزيد من الاعتماد عليها وكل هذا يعتمد في
الحقيقه على مكون رئيسي وهو الطاقات
المتجدده هل جميع الطاقات المتجدده ام
طاقه الرياح بشكل اساسي عاده بيهتم
المستثمرين بايجاد والعمل على المصادر ذات
الكلفه الاقل حاليا على مستوى الطاقات
المتجدده بتتصدر كل الانتاج الاكثر جاذبيه
من ناحيه وهي الطاقه الشمسيه تحديدا
الخلايا الشمسيه وايضا طاقه الرياح ولكن
هذا لا يعني اقتصار المنافسه بينهما ولكن
هناك الباب مفتوح للعديد من المصادر في
المستقبل وبحسب التطور التكنولوجي يمكن ان
ترسم هذه المصادر وغيرها في مزيج الطاقه
العالمي ان شاء الله وكيف تاثرت وستتاثر
مشاريع الطاقات المتجدده تحت الانشاء وتلك
المخطط لها في مصر في ضوء تحرير سعر الصرف
وعلى خلفيه نسب الفائده المرتفعه عالميا
هناك تحديات بيواجهها
القطاع الاعمال على مستوى العالم
وهو تحديدا معدل التضخم والذي شهد في
الحقيقه ارقام كبيره جدا سواء في الدول
المتقدمه او الدول الناميه انعكس مباشره
على توافر المكونات الرئيسيه لبعض
المشروعات وايضا تاثر سلاسل الامداد بهذا
من المؤكد ان هذا يلقي تبعات في الحقيقه
على قطاع الطاقه العالميه سواء في اعاده
تقييم المشروعات ايضا اعاده النظر في
اولويه تنفيذ المشروعات وما الى ذلك ولكن
الشيء المهم هو ان العقود المبرمه ما بين
المؤسسات المصريه وايضا القطاع الخاص في
الحقيقه بتنظر للامر من منظور عالمي بياخذ
في الاعتبار مسؤوليات كل طرف وبالتالي مدى
امكانيه استيعاب مثل هذه التغيرات
والتقليل من تاثيرها على مشروعات الطاقه
المتجدده هل هناك مشروعات تم تاجيلها لا
لا لم يتم اطلاقا الحمد لله عندنا مشروعات
حاليا في الطاقه المتجدده قيد الانشاء في
عندنا مشروع 250 ميجا وات في منطقه خليج
السويس باجمالي استثمارات تتجاوز ال 250
مليون دولار الحمد لله جاري التنفيذ من
الشركه المنفذه وهو مشروع تملكه هيئه
الطاقه المتجدده هناك ايضا مشروع بدا
العمل على انشائي بقدره 500 ميجا وات
مملوك لاحد الشركات الاماراتيه وان شاء
الله برضو يكون في خليج السويس والحمد لله
بدات الاجراءات هناك مشروعات اخرى في
مراحل مختلفه يجري العمل على تطويرها ان
شاء الله في ضوء خطط مصر لبيع بعض الاصول
هل هناك مشروعات تابعه للهيئه سيتم طرحها
امام مستثمرين خلال الفتره المقبله هناك
العديد من الموضوعات والطروحات التي
تشملها وثيقه ملكيه الدوله ومن ضمنها بعض
مشروعات الطاقه المتجدده المشروعات التي
يقصد بها هذا الاجراء هي مشروعات تكون
مملوكه للدوله المشروعات المملوكه للدوله
في الطاقه المتجدده بتتمثل في مجمع الرياح
بمنطقه الزعفرانه وده اجمالي القدرات
بتاعته حوالي 540 ميجا عندنا مجمع جبل
الزيت لطاقه الرياح وايضا اجمالي القدرات
الخاصه به 580 ميجا واط بالاضافه لبعض
المشروعات الخاصه بالطاقه الشمسيه سواء في
منطقه الكريمات سواء ايضا منطقه الزعفرانه
او في كومومبو وهذه الاصول يتم العمل على
تقييمها والعمل على يعني دراسه مدى
امكانيه ان تكون احد ادوات جذب الاستثمار
الاجنبي المباشر بالنسبه
للاستثمار في مصر هل تم تحديدها او تحديد
التوقيت المناسب للبيع يخضع كله في
الحقيقه الى الديناميكيات السوء والى ايضا
التقييم الخاص بالاصول ومدى جاذبيتها
بالنسبه للمستثمرين وايضا ما سيسفر عنه
المنافسه بين المستثمرين وبعضهم الله
تتوقف الان مشاهدينا مع فاصل قصير نتابع
بعده في مستقبل الطاقه في منتدى الاحساء
تحذير من ان تحول الطاقه غير المنظم اهم
خطر يواجه امن الطاقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى مستقبل الطاقه الحرب
الاوكرانيه وازمه الطاقه في اوروبا كشفتاه
عن صعوبات كثيره تواجه عمليه تحول الطاقه
عالميا المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه المتجدده ايرينا فرانشيسكو لا
كاميرا اقر في مقابله لمستقبل الطاقه بان
الاستثمارات في الطاقه المتجدده غير كافيه
وان هناك حاجه لمضاعفتها ثلاث مرات للوصول
الى الاهداف المناخيه المنشوده المقابله
اجرت الزميله سمر المشطلاعك
اوكي
جديده
[موسيقى]
ضمن فعاليات منتدى الاحساء للاستثمار هذا
الاسبوع انعقدت جلسه حواريه بعنوان فرص
الطاقه المتجدده في التحول والاستدامه
تطرقت الى انعكاسات صعود امن الطاقه الى
راس سلم اولويات الدول على مسيره ووتيره
التحول في الطاقه ومدى ارتفاع تكلفه
مشاريع الطاقات المتجدده في السنه الاخيره
في ظل ارتفاع كلفه التمويل وتضخم اسعار
المدخلات والمكونات كما تم مناقشه ما هو
مطروح من حلول تمويليه للقطاع الخاص في
المملكه لضمان اوسع مشاركه محليه في تحقيق
اهداف السعوديه بالوصول بالطاقات المتجدده
لتشكل نصف مزيج مصادر الطاقه الكهربائيه
بحلول عام 2030 لنتابع مقتطفات لابرز
مشاهدته هذه الجلسه
اعتقد اهم خطر على امن الطاقه اليوم هو
التغير المناخي واليوم اهم حل التغير
المناخي هو التحول للطاقه النظيفه
والمستدامه ولكن العلاقه بين امن الطاقه
وتحول الطاقه ليست علاقه طرديه هي علاقه
جدا معقده لا نستطيع ان نقول ان امن
الطاقه يؤثر على تحول الطاقه
ننظر الى سيناريوهات او اخطار الطاقه قبل
سيناريوهات التحول عندما نتحدث عن امن
الطاقه قبل التحول للطاقه النظيفه كنا
نتكلم عن تقلبات اسعار النفط كاحد اهم
الاخطار وتقلبات اسعار النفط كان يؤثر
بشكل كبير على سرعه او بطء التحول بخصوص
الطاقه اليوم نرى التحول الطاقه على ارض
الواقع ليست استراتيجيات ولا سيناريوهات
بل هي على ارض الواقع فالاخطار اليوم
مختلفه جدا تماما برايي اهم خطا الامن
الطاقه هو تحول الطاقه السيء والغير منظم
الواقع انه العالم متاثر بالتساوي
بمشكله التضخم ومشاكل الاقتصاديه والجميع
يمر بنفس التحديات هل ارتفعت تكلفه
المشاريع الطاقه المتجدده نعم اليوم نرى
انه قبل سنتين ثلاث سنوات السعر ارتفع ما
يقارب 30 40%
ولكن الحقيقه انه الميزه التنافسيه لمنطقه
الشرق الاوسط ولنا في السعوديه لا تزال
موجوده فبالتالي المستثمر وقرار الاستثمار
لا يزال موجود في الطاقه المتجدده
وسنفضل نحقق اقل نسبه تعرفها في مشاريع
الطاقه المتجدده على الرغم من هذه
التقلبات الاقتصاديه اللي احنا نمر فيها
فمقارنه بالعالم الاسعار سترتفع لدى
الجميع ولكن سنظل نحقق اقل نسبه
تعرفه لهذه المشاريع والاستثمار في البنيه
التحتيه هو مستدام وهو استثمار لاجل
المستقبل فقصه الطاقه المتجدده القصه
الجميله هذه لن تنتهي وسنظل نرى انجازات
جدا كبيره في هذا المجال ولن اعتقد انه
ارتفاع تكلفه المشاريع ستحد من الاستثمار
في الطاقه المتجدده خصوصا انها جزء اساسي
من
السياسات الخاصه بالدول بخصوص التحول نحو
الطاقه المستدامه استاذ مهند ما هو
الصندوق
الصناعي في دعم مشاريع انتاج الطاقه
المتجدده المستقله الاي بي بيس وعلى وجه
الخصوص شركات لربما مثل اكوا باور ومطورين
محليين
طبعا يمكن يمكن قبل الاجابه على السؤال
هذه يمكن ضروري جدا اننا نعرج على الخطط
الطموحه لحكومه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
في انتاج الطاقه المتجدده بحلول عام 2030
واللي مثل ما تفضلت استاذ ناصر نستهدف انه
50% من انتاجنا او ما يعادل 59 او 58 جيجا
واط بحلول عام 2030 تاتي من خلال الطاقه
المتجدده
وهذا يعني ولذلك نستهدف انه يكون عندنا
يعني 35 مشروع لانتاج الطاقه المتجدده
بطاقه انتاجيه تبلغ 40 جيجا واط كذلك
نستهدف انتاج 16 جيجا واط من طاقه الرياح
وحوالي ثلاثه جيجا واط من الطاقه الشمسيه
المركزه
فلذلك ان الدوله تقوم ببناء هذه المشاريع
بشكل كامل اصبح من الماضي وبالتالي اصبحت
الحاجه لوجود
الطاقه المتجدده المستقله اللي هي
لذلك الصندوق الصناعي وبالتعاون مع وزاره
الطاقه عملت على دعم
المصنعين المحليين والمنتجين المحليين من
خلال ايجاد حفظ حوافز ماليه تمكنهم من
المنافسه على ما يسمى من المشاريع الكبيره
وهذا بالتالي يجذب
الممولين التجاريه ان كانوا المحليين او
الاجنبيين من الدخول في هذه المشاريع
لانها محوكمه باتفاقيات شراء مسبقه من قبل
الدوله فخلقنا هنا مناخ كامل
لهذا المشاهدين ان ناتي الى ختام هذه
الحلقه من مستقبل الطاقه دائما تابعونا
على تويتر تحت وسم هاشتاق مستقبل الطاقه
شكرا لكرم المتابعه والقاكم الاسبوع
المقبل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]